>>> WE'RE GETTING W INSIGHT
INTO FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
THINKING AND ATTITUDE DURING HIS
YEARS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
BREAKING FROM 50 YEARS OF
TRADITION, CELEBRATED JOURNALIST
BOB WOODWARD IS RELEASING
RECORDINGS FROM HIS 20 DIFFERENT
INTERVIEWS WITH TRUMP AND
ISSUING A WARNING ABOUT HIS
SUBJECT.
WOODWARD SAYING ONE OF THE MOST
STRIKING THEMES IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S INABILITY TO REFLECT
AND TAKE ACTION ON THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS THAT WAS
ENVELOPING THE COUNTRY.
LISTEN TO ONE OF WOODWARD'S
EXCHANGES WITH TRUMP IN THE
SUMMER OF 2020.
>> WAS THERE A MOMENT IN ALL OF
THIS LAST TWO MONTHS WHERE YOU
SAID TO YOURSELF, AH, THIS IS
THE LEADERSHIP TEST OF A
LIFETIME?
>> NO.
>> JOINING US NOW, JOURNALIST
AND AUTHOR OF THE TRUMP TAPES,
BOB WOODWARD.
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING YOU'VE
NEVER DONE BEFORE, RELEASING
YOUR TAPES OF THE INTERVIEWS
WITH TRUMP.
YOU SAID HEARING THE AUDIO IS
MORE TELLING THAN READING THE
WORDS ON PAPER.
THAT NO IN THE LAST EXCHANGE,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS ALMOST
YELLING NO AT YOU LIKE HE'S
ANGRY.
>> WELL, AND HE'S DISMISSING ANY
RESPONSIBILITY HE HAS.
AND THAT NO IS LIKE A THUNDER
CLAP.
I'M WALKING AWAY FROM THIS.
I MEAN, IF THERE WAS EVER THE
LEADERSHIP TEST OF A LIFETIME
FOR THE PRESIDENT, IT WAS THIS
PANDEMIC.
IT WAS A HEALTH AND POLITICAL
CRISIS LIKE WE'VE NOT SEEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND HE WALKED AWAY FROM IT.
AND AS YOU LISTEN TO THESE
TAPES, PARTICULARLY ON THE VIRUS
BUT ON ANY SUBJECT, HE KIND OF
GOES FROM DENIAL TO CONCEALMENT
TO THE CRIME.
I CALL IT A CRIME.
NOT TELLING THE PEOPLE THAT HE
HAD BEEN WARNED BY HIS NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISERS IN THE MOST
VIVID WAY, WHICH IS OUTLINED IN
THESE TAPES, THE INTERVIEWS WITH
THEM WHERE THEY ARE TELLING
HIM -- I'VE DONE -- I'VE KNOWN
16 NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISERS
GOING BACK TO KISSINGER.
AND NEVER ONCE HEARD ONE COME
AND TELL THE PRESIDENT, THIS
WILL BE THE BIGGEST NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT TO YOUR
PRESIDENCY.
AND IT WASN'T ABOUT CHINA,
RUSSIA, OR IRAN.
IT WAS ABOUT A DOMESTIC HEALTH
CRISIS THAT HE WAS COVERING UP.
>> YEAH.
AND THAT HE SPENT THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND MONTHS POO-POOING
PUBLICLY.
THIS STRIKING CHAIN OF EVENTS IN
YOUR TAPES WE PLAYED EARLIER --
WE PLAYED THE SOUND OF NATIONAL
SECURITY ROBERT O'BRIEN AND
MATTHEW POTTINGER TALKING ABOUT
HOW THEY WARNED TRUMP JANUARY
28th THE CORONAVIRUS WOULD BE
THE BIGGEST THREAT IN HIS
PRESIDENCY.
TWO MONTHS AFTER HE WAS BORN, HE
HAD A CONVERSATION WITH BARRON,
BARRON, YOUNG BOY, SCARED OF THE
PANDEMIC.
HERE'S CONVERSATIONS YOU HAD
WITH TRUMP ABOUT HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH BARRON IN
MARCH.
>> I WANTED TO CAPTURE THE
MOMENT WHEN YOUR SON, BARRON,
ASKED YOU ABOUT THIS.
>> WELL, HE'S JUST TURNING 14,
SO HE WAS 13 IN THE WHITE HOUSE
UPSTAIRS IN HIS BEDROOM.
HE SAID, DAD, WHAT'S GOING ON?
I SAID, IT CAME OUT OF CHINA,
BARRON, PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
AND IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED.
AND TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
BARRON, THEY SHOULD HAVE LET IT
BE KNOWN IT WAS A PROBLEM TWO
MONTHS EARLIER.
WE HAVE 141 COUNTRIES HAVE IT
NOW.
AND I SAID, THE WORLD WOULDN'T
HAVE A PROBLEM.
WE COULD HAVE STOPPED IT EASILY.
>> OBVIOUSLY THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT, THERE IS A LOT OF
BLAME TO PUT AND ASSIGN TO THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
BUT HERE HE IS TELLING BARRON HE
WISHES HE KNEW ABOUT THE THREAT
TO CORONAVIRUS TWO MONTHS
EARLIER.
BUT TRUMP HAD BEEN TOLD ABOUT IT
LITERALLY TWO MONTHS EARLIER IN
JANUARY.
>> STUNNING, ABSOLUTELY -- I
MEAN, OUR PARENTS KNOW ABOUT
THAT MOMENT WHEN YOU DO TO THE
BEDSIDE OF A CHILD AND THERE IS
THAT HUMAN INTERACTION THAT
SHOULD BE BUILT ON TRUTH.
BUT TRUMP IS SAYING, OH, CHINA.
THEY COULD HAVE STOPPED THIS TWO
MONTHS AGO.
TRUMP COULD HAVE STOPPED IT TWO
WHEN I'M DOING THIS INTERVIEW
WITH TRUMP ON MARCH 19th, I HAD
NO IDEA -- IT TOOK ME ABOUT SIX
WEEKS TO FIND OUT ABOUT THE
WARNING, AND I FOUND OUT FROM
O'BRIEN AND POTTINGER ON MAY
1st.
AND WHEN I HEARD THAT FROM THEM,
I WAS AS STUNNED AS I'VE EVER
BEEN AS A REPORTER BECAUSE I GO
BACK AND LISTEN TO THIS.
AND MY GOD, TRUMP IS CONNING NOT
JUST ME BUT HIS SON.
AND HE IS LAYING OUT, OH, THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN FIXED.
THE CHINESE COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING ABOUT IT BY BEING
HONEST AND WARNING THE PUBLIC
THAT HE, AS PRESIDENT, HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL AND MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO.
>> AND THEN THERE'S THIS MOMENT
IN APRIL, APRIL 5, 2020.
TRUMP ASKS YOU WHAT ACTIONS HE
SHOULD BE TAKING TO COMBAT
COVID.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> GO AHEAD, DID YOU WRITE THEM
DOWN OR NOT?
>> YES, I WROTE THEM ALL DOWN.
>> READ THEM OUT.
GO AHEAD.
READ THEM.
>> OKAY.
FIRST IS TESTING.
>> AND YOU GO THROUGH YOUR LIST
OF WHAT YOU SUGGEST.
THIS IS MORE THAN TWO MONTHS
SINCE THE STARK WARNING ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC FROM NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER O'BRIEN.
THE PRESIDENT IS TURNING TO YOU
ON WHAT ACTIONS HE SHOULD BE
TAKING.
THAT MUST HAVE HAD YOU WORRIED
ABOUT THE STATE OF THE COUNTRY,
THE STATE OF THE RESPONSE.
>> BUT HE'S NOT TURNING TO ME,
FRANKLY.
I CALLED HIM UP, AND BETWEEN THE
PERIOD HE CLOSED THE COUNTRY
DOWN BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS AND
THIS APRIL 5th CONVERSATION, I
TALKED TO DR. FAUCI, DR.
REDFIELD, THE OTHER EXPERTS ON
THIS.
AND THEY SAID THEIR MEETING WITH
TRUMP, HE WILL NOT LISTEN.
HE'S GOT ALL THESE VIRUS DENIERS
IN THE ROOM.
AND I SAID, WHAT WON'T HE LISTEN
ABOUT?
SO, THEY LAY OUT A SERIES OF
COORDINATIONS AND SETTING UP
AIRLINE RULES AND DEFINING
SIMPLE THINGS LIKE WHAT IS AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER.
SO, I REALIZE I'VE GOT THIS
INFORMATION.
THEY'RE TELLING ME TRUMP WILL
NOT LISTEN.
I REALIZE I CAN TALK TO TRUMP.
SO, I SPEND ABOUT 15 MINUTES
GOING THROUGH THESE.
AND THE THEN AT THE END, HE
SAID, WELL, DID YOU WRITE THEM
DOWN.
AND I WENT THROUGH THEM AGAIN
THINKING, HE'S GOING TO DO
SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE DID?
ABSOLUTELY ZERO.
IT WAS SO SICKENING TO SEE HE
WAS NOT DOING THESE THINGS AND
HE'D LOST THE AVENUE OF
COMMUNICATION WITH THE EXPERTS.
I ASKED THEM AT ONE POINT, I
SAID, HAVE YOU EVER SAT DOWN
WITH DR. FAUCI?
HE'S THE EXPERT.
AND TRUMP SAYS, OH, NO, THIS IS
A BUSY WHITE HOUSE.
BUSY WHITE HOUSE.
DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO SIT DOWN --
I MEAN, IT'S LIKE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES NOT TALKING
TO HIS CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS OR THE COMMANDER.
I MEAN, IT'S ALMOST -- I MEAN,